alors après la libération de maurice
papon on aurait pu en rester là il
aurait pu choisir de se taire et de se
soigner
mais non à peine dehors ses avocats et
vous donc
hubert de beaufort vous parlez de
révision du procès et même de
réhabilitation tout à fait je veux dire
on m'a chargé de quoi moi je ne
connaissais pas papon avant son procès
ce sont les organisations gaulliste qui
m'ont demandé d'effectuer une contre
enquête
cette contre enquête démontre que pape
on ne peut pas être coupable de ce dont
on l'accuse c'est à dire de complicité
de crimes contre l'humanité on verra si
un autre procès en tous les cas en
entendant parler d'un nouveau procès il
ya quelqu'un qui a pris ça comme une
insulte à la mémoire du peuple juif
c'est julien dray il est là
et
bonsoir bonsoir alors julien dray et
contrairement à didier schuller vous
êtes contre la libération de maurice
papon
maintenant il est libéré mais quand
beaufort parle de révision du procès
vous entendez révisionnisme oui bah moi
je vais d'abord vous dire que ça ne
passe pas parce que maurice papon n'a
pas eu un seul mot à la mémoire de ces
victimes pas un acte de contrition
pas un regard mais il faudrait pas un
sentiment de charité faudra ici les
coupables parce que pendant que lui
était préfet de la république
d'autres étaient résistants et d'autres
mouret sous la torture
et eux mérité le respect alors comment
expliquez vous comment expliquez-vous
que jean-françois stener qui est juif
comme vous dont le père est mort et moi
je suis là en tant que député la
république pas en tant que juif d'accord
bon d'accord je suis content a été de la
rébellion
et en tant que citoyen français y'a pas
des juifs et des non juifs et donc si
vous voulez je pense que la libération
de papon et j'en finirai par là parce
que c'est pas un sujet de polémique la
libération de réponse c'est une insulte
à la mémoire non pas des juifs au milan
juifs les noirs de tous ceux qui n'ont
pas baissé la tête et qui dès 1940
on commence à résister alors vous
permettait de police qu'un concert
les pourparlers va pas refaire le procès
de mon nom mais qui devant la tente et
le jeu devant vous je voudrais pas vous
lire quelque chose vous pouvez me dire
tout ce que vous voulez la belle je vais
vous lire il ya toujours je sais la
théorie des révisionnistes s'est
toujours intéressée s'est toujours dit
rien à voir à écouter là je reconnais la
shoah comme vous un an mais c'est pas le
problème le problème c'est que la
justice française
elle a rendu un jugement qui a considéré
que maurice papon était coupable
bon d'accord elle l'a fait après impôts
c'est un procès équitable où il a pu se
défendre
ce que d'autres n'ont pas pu faire voilà
la réalité c'est tout point à la ligne
alors aujourd'hui monsieur pape on nous
a refait le coup de pioche et il était
dans un fauteuil roulant puis quand il
sort up
il est debout d'accord le plaisir de
cette bougie non je veux pas en sortir
17 enfants lui sauver le 17 mai 43 grâce
à maurice papon écouter un
extraordinaire sauvetage d'enfants juifs
fut rendu possible grâce aux mesures
prises par maurice papon après le
bombardement du 17 mai 43 à bordeaux une
assistante sociale de la préfecture ait
dit ses résultats
résistante protestante tenta une
initiative remarquable en vue de sauver
17 ans 19 enfants de la déportation le
15 juin 43 après un raid meurtrier de
l'aviation anglaise qui fit 350 morts
elle dépose à la demande suivante auprès
de la préfecture de bordeaux
monsieur le préfet je leur de solliciter
de votre haute bienveillance
l'autorisation de changement provisoire
de résident pour les enfants israélite
dont les ans suivent ça a été suivi par
maurice papon qui a obtenu la libération
des 19 enfants qui ont été sauvées et
alors puis-je vous lire vous permettez
g4 mot à dire l'ensemble de ces
témoignages ont été fournies au cours du
procès donc la justice de notre pays
ah oui je reconnais a eu ces éléments là
mais vous savez les hauts fonctionnaires
de l'époque ils avaient tous il avait
pris mon dealer bon juif un ou leurs
bons résisterez vous savez moi ça va
aller il fallait j'ai dit quatre mots je
dire qu'à trois mois par les quatre mots
les quatre premiers qui ont été sauvées
il s'appelait comment bret david drai
léon dre jacqueline et vous
michel alors et vous voulez quoi je
voulais vous dire que c'est que que vous
savez que vous êtes vous savez qu'il ya
des digues des milliers de grecs tombeau
qui sont endormis cuba qui sont très
graves grâce aux autorités françaises
oui cela il est sauvé grâce aux hybrides
parce qu'il fallait mais le problème
n'est pas là le problème c'est qu'il ya
du bois alors il ya 1600 enfants et
familles qui sont parties dans des
wagons plombés et qu'un préfet de la
république qui a organisé ces rares qui
a donné les ordres qui servit ce qui
allait se passer
voilà la réalité alors qu'après on
essaye de se racheter une conduite en
essayant de retrouver de 6 $ des
services qu'on a fait tout le monde a
fait ça à la libération vous savez dans
tous les procès tous ceux qui étaient
dans les bottes avaient toujours une
excuse
il avait toujours un résistant qu'il
avait protégé une famille qu'ils avaient
sauvé et qui essayait d'être l'heureux
sauf conduit par rapport à la réalité
monsieur pape on savait il on savait ce
qui allait se passer le savez pas vous
savez ce qu'il se passe des aliments il
collaborait avec les ramener à ne jamais
voilà le vrai problème jamais comme le
vrai problème se dresse et que
malheureusement le corps préfectoral
tout le corps préfectoral envers ses
malles louis sont jean moulin qui est
mort en martyr
mais le corps préfectoral dans son
ensemble à collaborer et à la libération
on a gardé une grande partie de ce corps
préfectoral c'est bien là le problème
papon on l'a trouvé 60 ans plus tard ce
qu'il allait chercher parce que nous
sommes latins on a fabriqué mais c'est
leur isolement la valoriser le mali
serait des six mois ne va pas non mais
tant que ces sources une raison il ya
des violeurs qui sont en liberté en
attendant que lors de l'euro mais on
doit pas le faire mais ce que je veux
dire ce que je veux dire c'est que à
travers papon on a peut-être voulu
essayer de ce jeu direct se purger c'est
autre chose
ah mais c'est le seul vrai problème le
premier président de la république quel
courage après françois mitterrand qui
lui pendant la guerre n'a pas été très
clair vous le savez croyez quand même
mais bon risque le premier président de
la république quel courage de
reconnaître la responsabilité la faute
la faute c'est du régime en chien
c'est juste de beaufort pense que c'est
cela qui a permis le procès par ses
activités j'accuse sinon il reste qu'il
faut avoir le courage de reconnaître que
l'ensemble de l'administration france
s'est indigné sous l'impulsion dont l'un
s'est produit voilà le problème c'est
qu'à part le problème c'est que papon a
été jugé bon
maintenant la sortie pour des raisons
médicales bon les gens en actions
d'accor ne sont pas d'accord globalement
on dit les vieux il sort mais maintenant
il veut une réhabilitation d'une
révision du procès ça c'est cette
demande n'a toujours pas par dans
l'armée vous tout à fait et monsieur de
vos formes 10 et dreyfus donc annoncé
par les moines avaient aussi ce que je
ne comprends pas franchement je lui ai
posé la question en prison je vous la
pose ici ce soir
posez là pourquoi ne demande t il pas
pardon pour les avoir d'après des actes
qu'il a commis comme fonctionnaire il
n'a pas commis il a tout ce qu'il a
essayé pendant qu'il était à il était à
bordeaux c'est d'essayer de limiter
alors de limiter au maximum les sas et
professeurs se trompe à ce moment ça
c'est exactement la théorie du maréchal
pétain
dès 1940 dans certains de nos
fonctionnaires qui étaient avec lui en
disant nous faisons cela pour attendre
le moment où les américains viendront
une histoire il a fallu attendre 1972 le
livre de monsieur paxton pour voir à
travers les documents qui ont été
révélés que tout ça n'était que du
discours que la vérité c'est que les
autorités de vichy avait partie liée
avec la commandante sûrs qu'elles
n'étaient en rien résistantes au
contraire qu'elle était totalement
partie prenante de l'idée d'une europe
allemande sous domination allemande et
dans laquelle j'ai autorités françaises
qu'il faut anticiper un contenant des
vidéos
c'est totalement faux c'est moi toute ma
famille a été toute ma famille a été
résistante est publié alors je vous en
êtes vous tout de même je sais ce que
c'est que la résistance dans la famille
sont celles beaucoup à la sks que mir
est demandé est ce que vous vous
demandez à maurice papon de moi de
demander pardon demandé pardon de quoi
de ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a fait mais
il na li na li na li na il n'a jamais
commis d'acte autre que d'essayer de
faire ce qu'ils pouvaient faire mais je
vais vous dire monsieur monsieur papon
quand il le se rendre compte qu'on
enferme des femmes et des enfants des
livrables dans les wagons plombés
quand il voit les tortures parce qu'il
le sait parce que les policiers les
raconte
que subissent les résistants quand ils
voient cette situation c'est un homme
libre il peut s'en aller il peut
démissionner mais il faut apprendre à
droite il n'a pas démissionné parce que
quoi mais parce que il est laid il un
problème avec sa conscience les autres
justement comme vous dites si elle ne
peut pas supporter cette vie peut faire
comme d'autres celle à rentrer en
détestant vous poser pourquoi elle et
pas rentrer en résistance
mais parce que le général de gaulle a
demandé aux fonctionnaires de rester sur
place
ah non le général de gaulle il a demandé
à résister contre les médias allemands
c'était là sa beauté c'est à dire à
prendre des risques
vous voyez sont l'elysée la priorité
après tout les joues sabler le champagne
avec la commande en tueur alors ridicule
votre vous avez été un collaborateur
d'un françois mitterrand je pas été un
collaborateur c'est un ami l'anem
mitterrand l'ami terre et j'en suis
français mais j'ai disputé des français
voulaient arrêter d'autres choses vous
saviez comme officiel hier contre
l'horreur c'était la consigne était
donnée un certain nombre de hauts
fonctionnaires
c'était d'organiser la résistance à
l'intérieur oui il ya eu et il y avait
des maisons n'avaient aucune n'y a aucun
réseau de résistance qui est venu dire
monsieur maurice papon a participé à la
limite je vais même aller plus loin on
peut comprendre qu'entre 40 et 41 ou 42
un certain nombre de hauts
fonctionnaires peuvent être je dirais
c'est d'une part les discours de pétain
en dix ans on a protégé une partie de la
france
on attend y aura une nouvelle mais à
partir de 42 tout le monde c'est la
réalité
tout le monde peut prendre ses
responsabilités en ne les a pas prises
si les a prises mais non ils rient les
abruzzes
il les a pris à son ami françois
mitterrand quant à mitterrand
je le savais dès que les bolides
allemands monsieur monsieur dray voilà
c'est complet d'un bon fort qui a fait
partir mitterrand qui a fait partie à
mitterrand en angleterre oui alain
beaufort qui a été fusillé par leicester
points 44 bon je dis simplement que tout
le raisonnement d'haleine beaufort
auprès de françois mitterrand est la
raison pour lequel congé mitterrand est
parti si tu as ces kalengo fort vous les
persuader mitterrand dû rester parce que
les les
les instructions du général de gaulle
c'était resté c'est le maire et finir
par nous expliquer que papon est un
grand résistant donc c'est quand même
pas là mais je ne dis pas qui est un
grand réseau
donc je dis qu'il a il a il a résisté
dans la mesure où il pouvait résister à
bordeaux alors j'ai fait un livre blanc
hubert de beaufort voulait envoyer un
certain nombre de personnalités vous
avez des réponses de yves guéna de
raymond barre de l'amiral de gaulle qui
nous ont dit être choqué par ce procès
qui a été fait donc un bruit comme ça
plus que ça guennadi par exemple que le
procès papon était le procès contre de
gaulle j'ai lu votre livre blanc alors
et je me demande si ce qui vous motive
finalement c'est pas tout simplement le
bon vieil antisémitisme français
non j'ai été administrateur d'une bande
juifs pendant dix ans keira pas ce que
c'est qu'une banque libre ah bah si
c'est quoi une bande lui pour vous et
battu une banque ou les l'argent du
nombre de j -p
on s'est mis n'est pas d'accord parce
que y'a des gens parce que des gens qui
sont d'origine hydraulique dans une
banque la banque jean bande juive
quand ils s'ennuient ils ont mis la
banque se glisser par exemple y avait
350 députés juifs à l'assemblée
nationale l'assemblée nationale sur une
assemblée juive non à bord il veut dire
quoi quand il quand ils ont ils
travaillent dans les organisations
jeunesse à se dire je pense que tous les
téléspectatrices été scrutin c'est pas
une crise s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît pas et 169 devriez livre blanc
allez-y vous dit
dans le cas de la shoah il s'agit de la
placer comme pilier de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
wim voudrait que ce soit quoi un détail
non mais non c'est un drame épouvantable
lachor un drame millions de morts oui
c'est oui c'est un drame épouvantable
grand mépris de l'histoire du site et je
veux simplement dire que j'adore demande
barbarie de ce genre de l'humanité tout
à fait c'est parce qu'il n'ya tout cela
dans toute l'histoire de l'humanité il
n'y a jamais eu une telle modification
citifx visant à distribuer à la
destruction sous la thématique des
preuves des enfants d'une histoire de la
mémoire et pas simplement au cours d'un
épisode c'est une volonté planifiée
organisée c'est pour ça que la shoah
dans l'histoire de l'humanité à un trait
particulier qu'on peut pas ramener tous
les massacres qui ont lieu aujourd'hui
encore et qui ont lieu tout au long des
siècles sur le même plan parce que
jamais les hommes non organisée de
manière aussi précise aussi systématique
avec autant de violence autant de
détermination et la destruction accord
oui voilà et sa mort
ça c'est clair alors ce qu'on veut dire
'attendez maintenant le dit deux mots -
o aux yeux des grands dirigeants que ce
qu'était roosevelt staline churchill et
de gaulle
je dis simplement que là le problème
juif n'a jamais été un problème central
pour eux s'était gagné la guerre et ils
ne vous il ne voulait pas que ce soit
mis en avant même lorsque il aurait pu
prendre un certain nombre de mesures qui
auraient limité
vous le savez très bien je me sens libre
rome c'est pour conclure je dirais tout
simplement monsieur de beaufort les yeux
dans les yeux je crois que le plus gros
reproche qu'on peut faire à votre ami
maurice papon
c'est d'avoir ni remords ni regrets mais
tout à fait de quoi voudriez vous qu'ils
n'aient remords et regrets parce que il
ya envoyé 1699 personnes dans les camps
d'extermination et tout le monde le sait
comme dit bernard henri lévy dans son
bloc notes du point il persévère et
ajoute outrage à la douleur alors il y
croyant maurice papon
oui un peu pendant pas énormément va
être énormément croyants comment doit
pas être énormément croyant et je ne
sais pas il est tout à fait ils allaient
à la messe à la santé il ya un aumônier
catholique qui vient une fois par
semaine et maurice papon assistait
systématiquement à la messe était dite
et ils demandant là donc des gens pardon
pardon pardon pardon non pas pardon
pardon activement pardon aux victimes
non mais il faudrait t'il qui se
considère comme coupable de ces d'avoir
d'avoir emmené ses victimes
n'est ce pas je veux dire s'il est
coupable moi je jeu chargé d'écrire un
livre blanc s'il est coupable je vous
dirais il est coupable
je n'ai aucune sympathie pour les
collaborateurs qui ont collaboré ma
famille qu'est ce que j'ai comme
souvenir moi je vais vous le dire mon
souvenir d'enfance à z en soit 14 15 ans
voilà j'avais 14 15 ans eh bien il ya un
des beaux forts un des frères beaufort
qui est fusillé dans la propriété par
les allemands il est fusillé par les
allemands et les allemands interdiscount
qu'on enterre son corps et c'est ma
grand-mère 70 ans qui de nuit dans une
charrette a mis le corps sous des fagots
pour aller l'enterrer en catimini voilà
le souvenir que j'ai par conséquent si
pape ont été collaborateur je vous
assure que je ne défendrai pas moi je
vais vous dire une chose c'est que vous
avez mis la mémoire de votre famille au
service d'une bien mauvaise cause je ne
le pense pas sinon je le ferai pas merci
mr de vaud fois